près d'un Français sur cinq vit à
découvert c'est ce qu'a révélé ce
mercredi une étude du Secours populaire
et de l'institut Ipsos l'inflation
plombe le pouvoir d'achat des foyers et
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
renoncer à certaines dépenses même parmi
les plus essentielles les indicateurs de
précarité atteignent ainsi de nouveaux
records en 2023 déplore le Secours
populaire 45% des Français interrogés
déclarent rencontrer des difficultés
pour payer certains actes médicaux 45%
du mal à payer leurs dépenses d'énergie
et 43% restreignent leur consommation de
fruits et de légumes frais dans ce
contexte les associations de lutte
contre la pauvreté font face à un afflux
de demande d'aide qu'elles ont du mal à
absorber tous les profils viennent nous
voir les étudiants les mères seuls les
jeunes personnes actives mais on a
également vu venir cette année des
personnes qui se débrouillaient jusque
là avec des petits revenus mais cette
montée de la précarité n'est pas une
exclusivité française précise l'étude
frappée de plein fouet par une inflation
sans précédent en 2022 près de 3
européens sur 10 déclarent de voir
renoncer à certains besoin de base comme
manger à leur faim ou chauffer leur
logement du fait de la baisse de leur
pouvoir d'achat plus d'un tiers des
Européens se restreint régulièrement sur
les quantités de nourriture qu'il
consomme bien que variables d'un pays à
l'autre la précarité alimentaire est une
réalité qui touche l'ensemble du
continent 38% des Européens sont des ne
font pas 3 repas par jour 39% renonçage
de la viande et 10% font appel à des
associations pour se nourrir à peine
relever du choc du covid-19 l'Europe a
été frappé en 2022 par l'explosion des
prix de l'énergie conséquence de la
guerre en Ukraine devenu moins
compétitive à l'international la zone
euro accuse un décrochage économique
tant vis-à-vis des économies asiatiques
que de son allié américain alors qu'ils
étaient presque l'équivalents en 2008
les Produits Intérieurs Bruts de la zone
euro et des États-Unis ont aujourd'hui
une différence de plus de 80% dans une
économie mondialisée ce manque de
croissance a des conséquences directes
sur le niveau de vie des Européens
affirme le Wall Street Journal les
Européens sont confrontés à une nouvelle
réalité économique qu'ils n'ont pas
connu depuis des décennies ils
deviennent de plus en plus pauvres